dc fandom coming later this month and so
today we're going to talk about a couple
things
one the suicide squad james gunn has
unveiled the new
sexy logo hell yeah for sex appeal and
the other thing is
ryan reynolds is getting involved in the
game in some weird ways
why not i want to watch this right now
this is the first thing i want to do he
put out uh here's his tweet here's the
secret reynolds cut
of green lantern you all have been
waiting for you all haven't been waiting
for
in order to make it as great as possible
we made some judicious cuts
i'm looking at the length i haven't seen
this it's only 27 seconds long
oh boy i that's a perfect cut to me
i finally saw green lantern only like a
month ago for the first time and john
hasn't seen it yet so this is gonna be a
perfect viewing experience
god damn that's beautiful
the green lantern picture break mark
three we'll find out soon enough
stupid son of a [ __ ]
there is no way you can succeed
[Music]
i wonder if that's what he's been
hinting at all this time oh
so fun i'm so glad he put the tom cruise
moment i know
this dude should edit reaction
highlights he should he should just have
his own
he's the one celebrity if he started his
own like reaction video channel i don't
think i would be upset
he even put out another tweet yeah i
don't know if this came before or after
but he said
i'm not playing hawkman in black adam
although i generally do whatever the
hell the rock tells me to do i would
however love to be in zack sanders
justice league movie
and i've heard i oh i may already be in
it
question mark i'm pretty sure yeah oh
the rock replied you are playing hawkman
and that's that
you're also dead man green lantern when
you want because you own the
intellectual property you're in the zack
snyder jail movie and you're also kevin
hart for real's dad like in real life as
per your blood test
uh i want that hobbs and whoever ryan
reynolds played
in hobson shot that's a perfect title i
want that movie
we're gonna get more green lantern in
the snyder cut because there's footage
teased
in justice league the one that we didn't
did of a green lantern in there from
what the visual effects designers have
talked about or whatever it's pretty
obvious we're gonna get more green
lantern now
zack snyder can figure out a way to make
it
ryan reynolds is green lantern oh kudos
why the hell not i highly doubt that's
the case but i would be
down for it i i highly doubt they want
to kneecap themselves like with a
banana peel at this point it would be so
distracting i mean like part of me would
leap for joy but yes i mean if you want
this movie to have integrity which i
think it it desperately has to prove
that it has
i think that would kind of undermine
things to have ryan realm show up at all
it could be cool i mean the thing is
he's always right now
in his ryan reynolds mode so i think
there's still a danger of it breaking
the reality of the movie a little bit i
think this is a great
judicious cut that he put together but i
also love that he's capitalizing
on this whole you know new director's
cuts release the aircut i want that hey
that makes for a great transition here
transish
james gunn has unveiled on twitter
release the gun cut
the suicide squad new
logo poster in all different languages
he said the suicide squad team just got
me these amazing new official title
treatments for my birthday and the cast
and i have
so much more to show you guys on august
22nd at dcfandome.com
see you there dc dc fandom at suicide
squad warner brothers
i love this logo uh because i saw it i'm
like this kind of looks like the dirty
dozen it got me excited at the thought
of james gunn making his suicide squad
movie in the
vein of the dirty dozen oh yeah it
already lends itself to it
you know like knowing what the dirty
dozen is being led by this kind of
cold-blooded ruthless individual amanda
waller these villainous characters
together
to do some good it's the suicide squad
you know totally
i don't know if it's the logo taking
this aesthetic design or if the movie
itself
tonally will fit in tune with it which
would be different than on
other james gunn movies but i still
think it could uh harken back to
something pretty cool
yeah well that's what i would hope for
from this version of suicide squad
because we've already gotten at least
the somewhat air cut
and so you know having so much going on
at marvel i think this would be a cool
way to show his versatility as
comic book movie director as a director
in general you know if he can bring
some of that gritty sort of yeah war
western you know
style to this that could be pretty sweet
when i look at suicide squad the
uh 2018 16
somewhere there 17. when i look at the
suicide squad logo for that one i feel
like
for the movie that we got that logo
reflects the kind of film that it is
i think that's important for logos to do
that because not only does it have
a bit of a dirty dozen vibe to it it has
a classics comic vibe
to it as well oh yeah i mean you can
literally just in the back of my mind i
can hear a 70s trailer
suicide squad you know and i feel like
you do want your title especially with
these movies and in such a visual medium
coming out of comic books i think you
want to your title treatment to
kind of give people a sense or an
association with what the movie ought to
be like so yeah i mean i wouldn't be
surprised at all if this matched pretty
heavily with the tone of the movie
oh actually i'd be more surprised if it
was like why did they go with that font
yeah well dc fandom is going to be an
exciting time subscribe click that
notification bell hit the like button if
you want ryan reynolds to come back or
if you like this suicide squad logo
catch you guys soon